[Music]
we're doing a um mega makeover hour and
i'm here with my old dear friend
charlotte tilbury who i've known for how
long charlotte oh my god i think it's 20
plus years yeah we're working with 25
teachers which is the group oh my god
people are so emotional getting them
ready like i've nearly been in tears a
couple of times like they're like i've
never seen my eyes look like this i've
never seen my skin my my it's like and
you're like so amazing these women and
chris appleton who i'm gonna do hair
with who's doing everybody here he he
makes hair for cancer patients and wigs
and he has always been such a good
person and for me makeup and hair has
never been about vanity it's about
empowerment it's all about empowerment
because it's all what i always say is
we're selling feelings yes feelings and
even more interesting i find is the
second you think you're okay and you're
taken care of is where you get bigger
and better for everyone else
i'm fine i'm not insecure i'm not
wrapped up in my own thoughts
i'm set free to then be outward bigger
and better and that's why i am so
grateful to do what i do and have this
line because i re i really started that
this because i was like i want to
democratize makeup because i always had
you in my chair or you know all the
celebrities i've worked with in the
world but actually i wanted to give it
to everyone
make it anyway
everyone well you know that darling i
remember when you told me you were
launching and i was like oh do you
remember oh my god
i remember you were like i want to make
velvet chairs in this whole world and
like this feeling and this whole setting
and you too darling flowers amazing oh
thank you and that's what i want to do
with the show is a feeling it's a
feeling it's the maya angelou quote it's
not the what people think of you it's
how you make them feel
invest all your stock in feelings and
feelings
[Music]
chris at what point can i give you my
head because i'm all yours too yeah i'm
ready whatever you want do it get in
there okay i am your clay
this is the most action i've had in six
years charlotte bring it on
that's not caught on camera
i'm like luckily there are cameras but
yeah it is
so
hard men never ask women out
yeah yeah go go go go
huh
yes that's really hot the amount of men
that want to probably date you like i'm
happier alone
oh but you see you're telling the
universe you're happy alone and i think
oh here we go you're not
so because the fact is
the background
you are hot sexy gorgeous
totally inspiring
and
you deserve to share that with someone i
do have kids too which makes a huge huge
difference in the fact that like but at
least i have a great love oh god you
have a great love but you can have it
all drew you know that
you have whatever you manifest said from
the woman who i believe
i'm looking at oh listen i've you know i
always like why do we have to limit
ourselves we can't just be have amazing
careers we can have it all we can have
kids
we can have it all
[Music]
we have got a beautiful lady oh my god
in our chair this is light work
an old an old horse
[Music]
i'm getting final touches i'm gonna go
in the other room throw something on and
then we're going downstairs to do this
welcome to our mega makeover
i'm hour living proof
i mean look at me i keep walking past a
mirror and being like who is that i just
thank you because this is so meaningful
for me to be a part of this mega
makeover hour with you guys thank you
really and true